thanks for the nice introduction and
good morning everyone it's so cool to be
here um it's my first international
conference and I'm really happy to meet
you all and be here in Budapest so I
actually said my name is Julia and we're
gonna talk about CSS games and drawings
if they are just fun or if they are
useful for something so first of all I
want to talk a little about me so I know
my name may sound Italian but I've
actually from Brazil and well I mean a
relationship with CSS since 2014 and
well this is a bit fun but I have to say
it was love at the first website and
well right now I'm a freelancer UI
developer it's opto which is cool
because I can work a lot with CSS which
makes me happy and as she said I'm a
cash sugar I have three cats and it's
just great to write CSS well my cat is
seated behind beside me that's great and
I'm sure hockey strawberry is number one
fan which are actually they are from
Japan but I'm not talking about the ones
from Japan they are actually cultivated
in a small town near my hometown and
this strawberries are awesome because
they are just the perfect mixture of
sour and sweet I'm Dino Kiki's best
friend he is my dinosaur and don't worry
I'm gonna talk about him in a couple of
sites so just hanging there about this
information okay enough about me and now
I want to know about you so I have a
question for you please raise your hand
if you have a cold just for fun if you
did a project create a lot of people did
it I'm really happy about it it's okay
if you didn't because sometimes we just
have a lot of work we have a lot when we
get home it's okay if you don't have
time for it or if you didn't right now
maybe we can change that by the end of
this talk who knows and also I want to
know from you if you did include this
fun project in your portfolio please
raise your hand fidget
okay good not a lot of people but that's
good so this talk is all about talking
about how our fun projects can impact
not only in our learning but also you
no portfolio and what these things can
do for our career if they have an impact
or if they're just a firm project we did
and maybe we like to share with our
friends
well as I told you I have this dinosaur
it's actually a website it's called Dino
Kiki calm you can access later but I
have to say it's a bit loud so just
don't like this in a public place maybe
it's a little while and well I curated
this in 2014 and back then I was an
exchange student at United States and I
really needed an internship I was just
starting with from and developing and I
wanted to know jQuery because it was a
hike back then and I didn't know a lot I
just learned that in the university so I
decided to create a project so I could
include in my portfolio and maybe get an
internship and it was a bit crazy idea
because when you click over him he just
speaks like the syllable Kiki in
different voices
so it's random every time you click over
and it's a different Kiki and also the
syllables will start popping up on the
screen and it was inspired by two things
which I kind of useless first is this
website called please pet dog you just
click over the dog and starts petting
him and random things like he's happy
you're petting him starts showing up on
the screen and also this vine I know
vine is dead I'm really sad about it
because I really loved buying about this
man walking in the street and screaming
Kiki and saying he was a dinosaur it's
mama dinosaur finds its baby
I like that fine so I put together both
of the things and created that website
and well it's actually listed on the
useless website so we can say it's
useless when we think about a business
perspective but it's not useless for me
I use it first to learn jQuery but I'm
still using it for example last year I
started working UJS so I decided to
change it to VJ s and lo j s instead of
jQuery and PHP which were a bit a little
bit outdated
and even today I have it on my portfolio
and even the job I'm currently in people
always look at it and say oh cool you
have the dinosaur
like and it's nice is that it's a way
that I created to learn new things or to
practice the things that I'm working on
and this talk it's about these things
and I just wanted to share with you this
example but no let's dive in this into
the CSS yeah I just saw about the
dinosaur but I promise it had a point
okay so it's about CSS drawings and
games so first of all I just want to
show a bit of what is our CSS draw is
what is a CSS game so I opened it here a
few code pens
this one was not a baby it was made by
this person called Marcin I guess it's
Peppa Pig okay don't you think this
person had fun well creating this I mean
I don't know why this person created
maybe Sheila he or he or they liked
liked it or maybe their children liked
it I'm not sure even though it's Peppa
Pig is a pretty simple drawing probably
it wasn't that easy to create this we
see a CSS especially when we consider it
has borders and ordered things and well
this one is when I created about the
solar system it's a bit animated and
this drawings are the base for the
presentation let me do right now so
every drawing on the presentation is
actually ice creams a screenshot of
something I draw with CSS and now about
games I found this really cool game it
was made by this person called Jerry low
it's in cold pan and it's made with only
CSS and you have to stack the yellow
squares over each other so for example
here okay it's working and then you lose
if you do this and then you can play it
again so it's an interesting game it's
nice and it's made only with CSS this
person probably had to learn new things
or practice in if you already know and
less there's this roaming I mean
probably you saw it on the Internet this
is just awesome this I mean it's really
hard to create something like this with
any kind of thing like even with paper
or with pain and we call it's just
awesome so I just want to remember you
all that CSS yeah also be art so I made
this emojis lies just to have to inspire
how I felt when I saw this and well know
hopefully you remember what CSS drawings
and games are or if you didn't know and
when is all of this when I did some I
was wondering every everything I learned
and how I liked this things and they
were helping me to exercise part of this
CSS and HTML things and I was wondering
if other people felt like it so I
decided to conduct a survey with
Brazilian developers because this area
was in Portuguese and I created a
Kitchener and shared on Twitter Facebook
and other social networks asking about
how people felt about these things so
the first question but there are six
participants 60 and the first question
was if they ever heard about CSS
drawings or games and I'm gonna make you
we were folks raise your hand again of
your time so I want to know from you
before the stop have you ever heard
about both of these topics or any of
these topics cool I was expecting a lot
of people because we're in at CSS comp
and that's great and I was expecting
also a lot of people to say they did on
my survey that happened I think
seventy-seven percent it's a good number
but then I decided to ask if this
developers created a CSS drawing I want
to know from you did you ever create a
lot CSS Joey yeah we got a similar
result
and most of people didn't then I decided
to ask about games I mean I was
expecting a very low number because I
think CSS games are something that are
not as popular and I promise this is the
last time did you ever develop a game
it's only HTML CSS and you are cool we
have people who did it and well my
survey we got like one person I was a
bit sad but most of all it made me think
about why why pee
but you know what it is maybe they
really love CSS but it's not a way they
usually experiment with CSS maybe they
do other kinds of experiments but I
asked it I also asked it this
participants if they learned something
new from this experience and they did
learn but I think this is one of the
things that make people not want to draw
or play or develop a game with CSS it's
something that is fun but maybe just the
people think is not something good for
their career which I completely disagree
because when we say something is useless
we're saying that it's useless in the
business perspective or something we do
in our everyday lives but it can be
useless
it cannot is not useless for us or for
other people who are working with this
technology and okay going back to the
part where I just said the participant
said it helped them to learn something
by creating the CSS games or drawings
and specifically I asked it a few topics
all of them said it helps you practice
creativity because sometimes you just
don't create a drama frontstretch but
you can still work on your creativity
why why are you a developing it and also
other technical topics such as CSS
positioning HTML tags CSS selectors
several elements and sort of and classes
in CSS and I was thinking like I told
you so I'm glad more people also learned
something it was not only me they the
people who created these things they
actually learn something from x but
there is this other code which I think
it's something that people say
especially when I talk about drawings a
lot of people say well not a lot of
people but someone say well you need to
be super creative about it I cannot just
make a drawing I don't have an idea for
it well it's true if you want to create
something new you need to have some
creativity but it doesn't mean that
every time you create a drawing or a
game you need to use your own idea like
100% you can't create it
using things that already exists so for
example my chip is if you don't have an
idea but you want to practice the SS but
creating a drawing you can recreate
something that already exists I did this
for example one of my first drawings was
this black cat from Sailor Moon called
Luna and I want to draw her I don't know
why I really like Sailor Moon when I was
younger and I searched on Google and I
decided to draw probably her head with
the moon over it and I created this code
but it's actually animator her ears move
and I was pretty happy with the result
because well I learned those things
especially how to create her cheeks and
everything else the moon so I could
practice things that I would get that I
am going to use on my job and well after
this okay I gave a shape how to start
but maybe people just say creating a
drawing is not like creating a website I
don't know how I can start I mean how do
you start a thing like that
so I created a cycle that works for me
it's not a rule you can use it if you
want if you already have yours that's
great it'll be cool to talk about it
please like let's know other regions
would you be ready to drawing and the
first step is you get an image and you
break it into geometric forms I'm not a
very good drawing on the paper but if I
create something that's on my head I
draw it very badly on paper and then I
try to break it into geometric forms
because by breaking into geometric forms
because it's easier to create something
in CSS from the geometric forms because
probably when we're developing a website
we already created like a circle or a
square or even triangle so it's better
to break these things step number two is
to use HTML to represent pieces of the
drawing for example you have a drawing
that have a head you can call you can
have a jib with a class called head and
step number three which is the one that
takes most of the time is to style each
piece of the HTML
so this cycle works for me but as I said
it's not rule right and we're gonna talk
a little bit about each one of these
steps and how we can create this a more
practical way so I am gonna choose Dino
keke as an example this is gonna take
his head which I made only with CSS so
first we break it into geometric forms
so here it is this hat is made by this
element some of them are repeated so we
have a kind of oval and a rectangle and
that yellow thing which like I have
circled I that's his mouth and his teeth
for this I'm gonna use his body or his
head in it as an example so I created
this day of called body and well there
will be another one for the eye another
one for the mouth and so on then I'm
gonna style using CSS so I broke it into
children choose their magic forms the
first one is the body which is an green
oval with border-radius to make it looks
like this and then there is another step
which is his neck which I use it the
potato element after which is just a
rectangle and well when we put both of
them together they look like Dino Kiki's
neck or head and you can do that with
different things if it's a more complex
drawing you're probably gonna have to do
it over and over again and you're
probably gonna have to worry about
pixels and how to combine things so
differently for a website which you can
use flexbox or grid in this case when
it's like a drawing from an animal or a
person I tend to use like left and top
positions more observable positions
because the same way as if we were
driving on the paper it would think oh
this looks better like right here so the
same thing happens with CSS it's just
one pixel I for one pixel right can
change the drawing so that's why I use
absolute positioning okay I talked about
drawings you may have an idea Hotch
greater drawing hopefully you really
think about I'm gonna make a drawing
let's think about what I'm gonna to draw
but I didn't talk about CSS
games they just showed one so not the
time to talk about CSS games and I'm
excited okay so I'm gonna present to you
I space team memory game this game was
made with no images no JavaScript no CSS
preprocessors everything our playing and
cool CSS and it's actually responsive
okay can we play that or the probably
sounds a bit boring but I don't think
it's boring so let's play it okay so
here's the game in the memory game it's
a set of cards that we have to find the
similar cards hopefully you play that
when you were a child
but if you didn't for example we have
like animals and we have to find the two
monkeys or the chuji laughs and then we
set this card Society this one is made
with planets and on the solar system so
the first thing I do is I click on the
card and it shows the planet then I have
to find another similar one well if it
they are not similar nothing happens and
the same way I would play with paper
that I have to turn the cards back and
from I would turn them back again but
let's figure let's think I found a
similar one okay I know it's this one so
when you find similar ones it has this
small animation saying hey you find me
and then I change the background and
well then you can keep playing it is
responsive so for example if I change
for like a smaller screen here it is I
use a CSS grid to make another order of
the cards so it's not Wrentham because I
don't have a random function in CSS at
this time but you can change the thing
three different screen widgets and then
they change the order of the cards so
you can play it again that won't be
boring for example here is not it's
actually Venus and if you open it it's
in another position okay so now I'm
gonna cheat a little bit to show you
what happens when we play all of the
game and we win please don't tell
one that I was doing this okay so I'm
gonna select all the cards okay done
I want again or it gets happy and say
yeah you won and then you can refresh
the page and play it again if you want
it so this was made only with CSS the
drawings are the one from the solar
system drawing I show you earlier and
well hello let's talk about how this
game was built any more technical way I
think the main question I had when I
wanted to do this game is how could I
create a click basic action without a
JavaScript event because usually when we
think about clicking things and
interacting with things we always think
about clicking with JavaScript depending
if you're using vanilla JavaScript or a
framework it changes but it's always a
kind of on click event the secret at
least for me on this case it was to
combine label and checkbox because if we
think about your checkbox well it
changes its appearance when we click
over it so if you click on the label
it's check if you unclick if you click
again it's unchecked so this allow us to
have a label and change the state of
this checkbox and this is the move the
beginning in China of this game so for
example each card both parts of the
stars and the planet are labels I've
done the checkbox it's not visible
actually so that's why it's a blank
screen so it's hidden you don't see the
checkbox but there's actually actually a
checkbox for each one of the cards the
cards are a label for a hidden chat box
and here's an example of the code so we
have an input this example is for the
planet Mars and then we have the label
which have two sections the first one I
call card front which is the place that
the stars go this each of one of the
stars it's a see HTML chip it's just
like a white point like two pixels I
think with some opacity reduced
and then there is the card back which is
just a planet and the text of the planet
so both of them are on the label and I
just changed their visibility according
to the checkboxes state so let's think a
little bit more about the game logic and
this is something I just realized when I
when I was creating the game and I think
it's really cool it's allowed me present
this year I really like cycles so this
is the last one from the presentation
but the first thing that happens when we
start playing with the car is that you
click over the car when you click on it
they change both the checkbox we've
changed it to stay so if it was not
check it you can check it and vice versa
and then it will change the visible part
on the car but let's think a little bit
more about the step number two about the
check box so there are different states
they're different phases actually
there's the first one when the when you
start playing the card and all the cards
are with the Stars showing then you can
click over it and it's going to show the
planet and also there is the third one
which is when you click all of the cards
and you won the game so the case number
one it's when the checkbox get becomes
check it this is the cool thing if you
look at the code and you think how to
create a game you'd ended up trying to
use try to use conditionals such as a
else but there is no such thing in the
CSS so how do we create a similar
behavior if we don't have an if in CSS
because we want you click on the card
and if the stars are visible we're gonna
hide the Stars and show the earth or
another planet so here's the code I use
it to simulate this if which is I'm
gonna when the check box first is
checking then I'm gonna show the part of
the card which called card front so I'm
hiding this sorry I'm gonna hide this
part the card front which are the stars
and then in the same case which means if
the checkbox is checked
I'm gonna show the card back part which
are the planets witches
or and then there's the keys number two
which is the opposite it's actually
going back to its isness initial state
which is else if the earth is visible or
the stars are not visible I'm gonna hide
earth and display the Stars which is
just going back to the original state
which is not showing the card back which
is earth and then display in the card
fronts which are the stars and the case
number three which is when you won the
game you select all the cards you did
right you'll play the memory game and
then both of the planets the similar
planets are visible in this case earth
number one is visible and number two is
visible then I'm just gonna make the
background darker and include a small
animation and here it is so I think this
is school because when I look about I'm
gonna explain this what I can simulate
is like well if oryx's check it and
number two is check it then I'm going to
change the background color of the card
back so I think when we are using CSS on
our jobs creating website business
applications sometimes if we don't stop
and look at the selectors like this we
just keep doing our CSS and we have so
many things sure it is the code clean am
i using new technologies and it's pretty
cool to experiment and look at the CSS
in another way I think it's good and
you're probably gonna use that on work
later maybe there is one way that you're
gonna need to use the selectors or
create something similar to an if and
maybe you just haven't thought a lot
about it yet you just didn't give you
time to do that and well I created this
game initially because I wanted to use
CSS grid and I was working a lot with
sass but I really wanted to use he
assess custom properties so there are a
list of few things that I wanted to
learn by creating this game but after I
created it and I started looking at the
code okay we have a notification
well I realized I learned more things
than I was expecting so here's here's a
list so as I told you CSS grid because
that was the main point of creating this
game and CSS custom properties but I
ended up learning more about the
limitations often for checkbox and do
HTML tags it's something that we use
maybe you already know but it's cool
practice and to explore it to its limits
it's nice to see what we can do with the
checkbox because when we are using your
lineup on our applications maybe we
don't don't see how important it is or
how cool it is now I look at the
checkbox in another region it's cool and
also animations and transitions with CSS
I think animations and transitions is
something that is really cool to learn
with drawings because you can animate
them and you can do crazy things with
them and it's really important to use
transitions on your website but you know
if you include too much it's not good
but if you not conclude it it's also not
that cool so it's a really nice way to
try and probably I learned more I mean
I'm talking with you so maybe I learned
also how she talking with people a lot
lots of people I don't know so it was a
really cool experience
I created other games after that and
probably I'm going to create more in the
future but that's not all
hopefully you are motivated to create a
drawing or a game I don't know I know we
still have two more days of conference
and maybe we have a lot of work next
week because we were in the conference
but when you have some time if you're
interested you would be really cool if
you try to make one and make a list of
the things you want to learn and the
things you learned it's really nice to
see your progress and it's a really cool
way to learn more things because there's
so many ways you learn right I mean all
any courses we can take classes we can
talk to people and this is just another
way that you could have fun with if you
were tired of other methods of learning
try anyone try to experiment something
try to educate something that you think
it's cool it doesn't need to be super
used it's super useful for business
application but it can be your
experiment your thing and that's okay so
if you ended up great and running
that'll be so cool and if you do please
share it on your social networks and let
me know let's see some with the past no
because it would be really cool and here
are the links for the game so if you
want to play the game it's some code
bang you can find me on hold pin but
that's also this link so maybe it's
easier to find and the presentation is
already live on this thing so I also
include the links for the other drawings
is everything on the last slide so if
you're interested in checking the games
and the drawings out please check it on
the rail and pictures okay I just wanna
say thank you for all of you to being
here and she seen this I really hope
that I made you look at the drawings in
the games in a different way I mean they
can be used for your career they are a
method of learning so please just try it
if you have some time I think it's worth
it so thank you and I don't know I hope
you got it and this is my Twitter
username if you want to talk about games
or if you want to brainstorm ideas for
games on Twitter or here I'm available
and thank you so much
[Applause]